sí
hola me llamo eben ostby he trabajado en
pixar desde que éramos solo unas seis
personas haciendo cortometrajes
experimentales una cosa que sigue igual
desde entonces es la necesidad de
cámaras virtuales para entender las
cámaras virtuales necesitas saber cómo
funcionan las cámaras físicas me
encantan las cámaras las colecciono las
arreglo e incluso las construyó
construye está en un sistema que la
imprimí con un sistema de impresión 3d y
toma fotos así
hay cámaras de todas las formas y
tamaños
como esta pequeña con binoculares
y esta arbus que es una clásica
estadounidense
en pixar cuando diseñamos una cámara
virtual debemos hacer un modelo de lo
que sucede dentro de las cámaras físicas
alguna vez te has preguntado qué hace
realmente una cámara cuando tomas una
foto probablemente sepas que una cámara
captura la luz sobre una película o
sensor de imagen para entender cómo
funciona construyamos una cámara muy
sencilla empezaremos con una caja será
el cuerpo de nuestra cámara y con una
hoja de papel que representa nuestro
sensor de imágenes o película llamaremos
al papel plano de la imagen saben que
hagámoslo a grande escala y usemos una
oficina como si fuera nuestra caja
nuestra escena se encuentra del lado
exterior de la ventana y nuestro plano
de la imagen está en la pared opuesta no
vemos una imagen clara el problema es
que todos los puntos del plano de la
imagen están siendo bombardeados por
toda la luz del escena exterior
lo que queremos es que cada punto del
plano de la imagen reciba la luz de una
pequeñísima zona de la escena mira lo
que sucede si cubrimos toda la ventana y
solo dejamos un agujerito llamamos a
este ojito estenopo o apertura de
nuestra cámara
si dejas que tus ojos se acostumbren por
unos minutos ya está una imagen
la razón por la que funciona es porque
el estenopo solo deja pasar algunos
rayos de luz en este punto aquí sobre el
plano de la imagen solo pueden pasar por
la apertura los rayos de luz de una sola
dirección esos rayos vienen de la luz
que rebota en este lugar de la escena
así que el estenopo filtra los rayos de
luz que no provienen de la dirección
adecuada este sencillo diseño de cámara
se conoce como cámara estenopeica si
reemplazamos la pared trasera del cuarto
con una película fotográfica enorme
podríamos tomar una foto gigantesca
sabías que la palabra cámara viene del
latín y significa habitación las
primeras cámaras se conocían como cámara
obscura
de hecho eran del tamaño de una
habitación como nuestra oficina en el
ejercicio siguiente puedes usar el
simulador con una apertura para tomar
algunas fotos virtuales puedes ajustar
el tamaño de la apertura y presionar
aquí para tomar una foto
mientras lo haces tendrás que responder
algunas preguntas sobre qué está
ocurriendo como por ejemplo porque la
imagen está de cabeza y más importante
qué pasaría si cambiáramos el tamaño de
la apertura
nos vemos al rato